[Música]
Bienvenidos a una semana en el mundo el
programa de Franz 24 donde los
periodistas son los invitados y
conversamos sobre las noticias que han
marcado la actualidad Internacional de
la semana en esta ocasión vamos a hablar
vamos a plantearnos Por qué la historia
con trágico final del sumergible titán
ha traído de esta forma la atención
mediática internacional también
hablaremos sobre las los movimientos en
las relaciones entre China Estados
Unidos y la India que se han dado a lo
largo de esta pasada semana finalmente
también comentaremos Cuáles son las
alternativas al modelo bukele frente a
la violencia de las pandillas en
Centroamérica y cerraremos con un
comentario sobre la ambivalencia de
Francia liderando la lucha contra la
crisis climática a nivel internacional
antes de empezar saludamos como siempre
a nuestros invitados empezamos aquí por
el estudio de France 24 en Bogotá donde
nos acompaña ser Guzmán Él es director
de Colombia risk análisis Sergio
Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en France 24 le pregunto
rápidamente con qué tema hace rostro
esta semana en que estaba poniendo la
atención Bueno es un placer estar acá
Muchas gracias el tema que está causando
furor en Colombia hoy es una declaración
de emergencia económica que quiere hacer
el gobierno de Gustavo Petro para
enfrentar la sequía que este momento
está afectando la alta guajira y
potencialmente avanzar en los trabajos
de transición energética con las
turbinas eólicas en ese departamento
Sergio pues muchas gracias un tema que
conversaremos en otra ocasión ahora
vamos a Ciudad de México donde se
encuentran nuestros otros invitados en
el programa de hoy empezamos por tamaris
Greco periodista y documentalista
Damaris Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en France 24 le traslado
la misma pregunta con qué tema cierra
usted la semana
Gracias el nombre stemoris Bueno estamos
en ese ingreso en esta semana se produjo
la reactivación de una serie de órdenes
de aprehensión que habían sido
abruptamente canceladas sobre el caso de
atzinapa contra dieciséis militares que
están acusados de haber estado
involucrados y al mismo tiempo se
tradujo se se informó de la inminente
salida del delgía y el grupo
interdisciplinario de expertos
independientes que es el que derribó la
mentira histórica de caso yo chinapa que
había fabricado el gobierno anterior que
ahora siente que su confianza pues no no
ha sido
debidamente
resuelta por el gobierno actual y en el
que se encuentra Ángela buitrago la una
una muy importante y muy apreciada
fiscal colombiana que ha estado estos
años aquí trabajando sobre el caso de
Salvador Fausto nuestro otro invitado
también desde Ciudad de México no sé si
el caso hallochinapa también es el que
ha centrado su atención al final de esta
semana o si ha sido otro
sin duda El caso
es uno de los temas más relevantes que
están ocurriendo ahorita en México sobre
todo por las órdenes de captura que se
liberaron contra
al dieciséis o diecisiete
militares estuvieron involucrados en el
en el caso de la desaparición de
cuarenta y tres estudiantes de la normal
de Ayotzinapa y que quiso ocultar y que
participó como cómplice el gobierno
anterior de enrico Peña Nieto y a la par
Pues en México estamos en sus en una
sucesión adelantada en la cual tenemos
ahorita seis aspirantes presidenciales
a un año de las elecciones que ya están
haciendo campaña
y hicimos un reporte reciente de que en
México
estas elecciones adelantadas es ya el
pan nuestro de cada día es decir en
cinco elecciones presidenciales que van
en este siglo las cinco han sido
adelantadas es decir
hace en el 2000 el candidato que llegó a
la presidencia arrancó su campaña tres
años antes de las elecciones sí y en
promedio todos han sido tres años antes
ahorita la sucesión presidencial está
adelantada por un año y Bueno pues tiene
la atención de todos nosotros por estos
momentos Pues a Salvador un tema al que
le dedicaremos más atención sin duda
también en otros programas aquí en
France 24 ahora Les propongo empezar
esta Edición de una semana en el mundo
con el tema que sin duda ha ocupado la
mayor parte de los titulares
internacionales a lo largo de los
últimos días Estamos hablando del
sumergible titán que recordemos
desapareció el pasado Santo Domingo 18
de junio con cinco personas a bordo se
dirigía recordemos a las ruinas del
Titanic en una expedición turística de
la empresa privada oceangate fue sin
embargo el lunes cuando la noticia saltó
a la prensa internacional y en ese
momento los medios de comunicación
empezamos una especie de Cuenta atrás
minuto a minuto calculando el oxígeno
que quedaría eventualmente dentro de la
nave paralelamente las autoridades tanto
de Estados Unidos como de Canadá
apoyadas por las autoridades francesas
empezaron una búsqueda por mar y por
aire de este sumergible una búsqueda que
ayer llegó a su Trágica conclusión por
decirlo de algún modo cuando la guardia
costera de Estados Unidos informó que
habían encontrado fragmentos que se
corresponderían con los restos del titán
de este sumergible y que todo apuntaría
a que pocas horas después de sumergirse
cuando perdió la comunicación con la
superficie habría sufrido lo que
llamaron una implosión catastrófica
escuchemos les ofrezco a la portavoz de
la guardia costera dando esta noticia
esta mañana un vehículo operado por
control remoto del buque Horizon Arctic
descubrió el cono de la cola del
sumergible titán Aproximadamente a 1600
pies de la prueba del Titanic en el
fondo del mar
Posteriormente se encontraron escombros
adicionales
en consulta con expertos del Comando
unificado los escombros son consistentes
con la pérdida catastrófica de la cámara
de presión
pues Sergio empiezo por usted que se
encuentra aquí en los estudios de France
24 le pregunto empecemos por el
principio porque cree que esta historia
ha traído tanto la atención a nivel
internacional bueno es una historia que
tiene muchos elementos un millonario el
Titanic una aventura oceánica un
desaparecimiento es muy fílmica o sea
tiene una narrativa pues demasiado
atractiva y fácil de entender para
muchas personas la claustrofobia es un
miedo que todos tenemos Entonces es muy
fácil conectar con una audiencia no
tanto así por ejemplo temas como
migración sí es más difícil conectar
precisamente
que hace esta comparación La recojo y se
la traslado a Salvador desde Ciudad de
México le planteo precisamente considera
oportuna esta comparación Inevitable
respecto a la atención que se atribuye a
las personas que están también en
situación de peligro en alta mar en este
caso en otra zona geográfica en el
Mediterráneo donde tanto la semana
pasada que naufragó frente a las costas
de Grecia una embarcación con cientos de
personas como esta misma semana en que
cerca de 40 personas han muerto frente a
las Islas Canarias en España después de
pedir auxilio durante 12 horas según
caminando fronteras le parece que está
comparación merece merece la pena
merecer nuestro interés ver un poco cómo
se comporta la prensa las autoridades
Claro porque
mediáticamente
el la aventura digamos el viaje de cinco
personas el fallecimiento lamentable de
cinco personas que iban en un asunto
turístico a buscar conocer los restos
del Titanic un asunto muy sexy
que acapara pues mucha atención tiene
una atención de telenovela
en los medios no solo de de América
Latina del mundo
entero y sin embargo vemos el
fallecimiento de cuarenta migrantes en
altamar ya sea en las costas del
Mediterráneo ya sean en en México
imagínense lo que ocurre en México
cotidianamente es decir que decenas de
migrantes fallecen en tráilers
encerrados
o intentando cruzar un pequeño río que
divide a México con Estados Unidos no
acapara la atención mediática como lo
hace estos turistas millonarios que
intentaban llegar a a conocer el Titanic
sin duda de ese llama la atención cómo
es posible que nosotros los periodistas
le prestemos mucho más atención a un
asunto en el que los elementos
noticiosos son atractivos millón un
millonario el Titanic o varios
millonarios entonces sin duda pone sobre
relieve el problema de la migración por
tratarse del mismo escenario es decir
altamar los mares la idea de de
trasladarse y Buscar conocer otros
paraderos
sin duda es un asunto que debemos
reflexionar quienes
le quiero trasladar esta reflexión A su
compañero temories también desde Ciudad
de México Qué opina usted de esta
diferencia tan abismal entre Cómo se
trata un naufragio de personas migrantes
o cómo se ha tratado este hundimiento
Bueno creo que en lo que lo que comentan
los señores Guzmán y Frausto nos indica
las las deficiencias de nuestras de de
sociedades del espectáculo que los
medios pues se prestan a reproducir el
un periodismo entendido como un oficio
que debe servir a la sociedad Y que debe
ser servir a las personas más más
vulnerables debería tratar de hacer
énfasis o debería hacer hacer énfasis en
la tragedia de personas que están
intentando buscar una una mejor vida y
que y que y que si están siendo
perseguidas hostigadas aisladas y
finalmente conducidas a naufragio por
los servicios costeros de Naciones qué
qué presumen de de sus regímenes
democráticos y de la defensa de los de
los Derechos Humanos el la pasión social
o o de muchos sectores por las vidas de
los de los de los millonarios conduce a
reforzar esta idea de que las vidas de
ciertas personas que nacieron en el
privilegio tienen muchísimo más más
valor que las vidas de las personas que
solamente están buscando mejores
condiciones Entonces yo creo que que lo
que señala Esto no es solamente es una
falla social sino una una falla en un
sistema de medios de comunicación que
sigue
prestándose a estos a estas
discriminaciones reales sí tengo que
decir precisamente el hecho de que estas
personas fueran tan privilegiadas fueran
hombres blancos multimillonarios por
otro lado a desencadenado sobre todo en
internet una especie de humor podríamos
decirle qué clase no de la clase
trabajadora contra la clase alta en
forma sobre todo de memes Les propongo
que veamos uno de los muchísimos que han
circulado en internet a lo largo de
estos días vemos a una horca que también
en una especie de crossover con otro
tipo de memes recordemos las orcas
también han saltado los titulares por
protagonizar su propia Cruzada contra
los yates privados en los últimos meses
pero esta horca respecto al hundimiento
del titán dice no tengo nada más que
Añadir que it the Rich no comanse a los
ricos por lo que hay personas que han
reaccionado a este tipo de humor
diciendo que era inoportuno o con la
falta de tacto rápidamente para concluir
con esta cuestión Sergio Usted qué opina
este humor es oportuno o no es oportuno
yo siempre pienso que la gente va a
buscar hacer levedad de los
acontecimientos así sean estresantes o
inapropiados o no Yo creo que digamos la
reflexión a la que debe invitar es
porque cuando se habla de
multimillonarios no escatimamos en
recursos para salvar sus vidas pero
cuando hablamos de refugiados o
migrantes ahí sí el costo de atenderlos
si es una cuestión política
rápidamente les traslado esta esta
última comentario a Ciudad de México
atemorizar qué opina de este de este
humor de esta reacción también Pues el
humor siempre ha sido una de las pocas
formas en que los pobres pueden tomar
venganza de los ricos y y es Entonces
cuando los ricos no se aguantan y
reprimen a los humoristas y reprimen a
la gente a mí a mí me dio mucha risa lo
de la orca no la había visto y suscribo
lo que dice la compañera y Salvador
brevísimamente
No pues Sergio tiene razón pone el punto
en lo más interesante Cuántos millones
de dólares se gastaron en Buscar a cinco
millonarios Y cuánto dinero se invierte
por parte de los países en tratar de
salvar a los migrantes que buscan una
mejor vida Eso me parece que tiene a
nuestra sociedad lejos de las causas más
nobles y coincido con temoris
suscribo lo que dijo la orca pues eh
Muchas gracias por sus comentarios
respecto a este tema les invitamos a la
reflexión a ustedes también desde sus
casas y Les propongo que pasemos a otra
cuestión a que también nos ha mantenido
muy ocupados a lo largo de esta semana y
ha sido los movimientos diplomáticos que
ha habido entre China Estados Unidos y
la India recordemos este lunes concluyó
la esperadísima visita del secretario de
estado estadounidense Anthony blinken a
China una visita que había sido ya en el
mes de febrero por el episodio del
llamado globo espía uno de estos
episodios que en los últimos meses han
elevado unas tensiones Ya de por sí
bastante elevadas desde hace años
tensiones en relación a la guerra en
Ucrania a la guerra comercial por la
tecnología los semiconductores los
Microchips a la cuestión de Taiwán a las
visitas de Estados Unidos al paso por
Taiwán de pelosi las prohibiciones de
tiktok entre Estados Unidos las
acusaciones a China por fabricar los
productos a base del fentanilo entre
muchísimas otras cuestiones que no
terminaríamos nunca de enumerar Sin
embargo al concluir esta Esta visita
tanto china como Estados Unidos
calificaron el encuentro de forma
positiva aunque con calificativos
tímidos pero digamos que celebraron el
encuentro dijeron que las relaciones
Iban por el buen camino sin embargo Un
día después de que Anthony blinken
cerrara esta este encuentro donde fue
recibido por el propio presidente el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
calificó al presidente chino de dictador
esto en un encuentro en California para
recaudar fondos para el partido
demócrata escuchemos las palabras
exactas el motivo por el que se enfadó
cuando derribé ese globo con dos
compartimentos llenos de material de
espionaje fue que no sabía que estaba
allí habló en serio Eso es una gran
vergüenza para los dictadores cuando no
saben lo que ha pasado escuchemos ahora
la respuesta china a estas palabras
los comentarios de la parte de Estados
Unidos fueron extremadamente ridículos e
irresponsables han violado gravemente
los hechos básicos y el protocolo
diplomático así como la dignidad
política de China
para cambiar ahora el orden de las
intervenciones Salvador empiezo por
usted considera que este comentario de
Joe biden fue algo desafortunado o fue
una provocación adrede
me parece que es una provocación que
tiene que ver con la atención que hay
entre el gobierno de Estados Unidos y de
China y que en el caso de para aterrizar
el asunto en un asunto que tiene que ver
con nuestros países con los países
latinoamericanos
y también con estas dos grandes
potencias está el tema del fentanilo en
medio de eso los estadounidenses Están
preocupados por la gran cantidad de
muertos que hay en el en Estados Unidos
por parte por el consumo de fentanilo
que ha crecido muchísimo y que en México
acabamos de tener la noticia de que han
cambiado seis veces a los directores de
aduanas que es donde llega el fentanilo
o los precursores para
diseñar el fentanilo que se diseña en
México y se traslada hacia los Estados
Unidos entonces hay ahí una atención
internacional sobre un asunto que
preocupa muchísimo a los estadounidenses
por la cantidad de muertes que está
causando y por otra parte por el gran
negocio que está generando en la
industria de las drogas y del crimen
organizado el tráfico de fentanilo
Salvador Pues ahora volveremos a los
impactos de esta de esta tensión
diplomática entre las dos grandes
potencias a mundiales para América
Latina Pero antes para no perder un poco
el hilo de los acontecimientos
temoris le planteó a usted considera que
recibiera Antonio blinken fue un símbolo
digamos de buena voluntad de intentar
demostrar que quieren que por lo menos
en la superficie las relaciones sean
correctas
Bueno a mí me parece que a los que a los
dirigentes demócratas les está fallando
el pulso Ellos están bajo asedio del
sector más extremista del partido
republicano el de El el de Donald Trump
y y está intentando
transmitirle a la sociedad que ellos
pueden ser duros duros este en diversos
temas como el de las drogas como el de
la migración o como el de China pero
te parece que están actuando en contra
de su propia diplomacia ya lo hizo Nancy
pelosi con su con su visita sin motivo
alguno a Taiwán que provocó que se
elevaran las las tensiones y ahora
justamente en este momento en que
Anthony fue recibido en Beijing
sale biden con este comentario que no se
sabe a dónde va ni De dónde viene ni por
qué son los dictadores lo son Pero eso
parece Pero no es no es tarea de baile
en señalarlo A menos que quieran
mandarle un mensaje no no a la comunidad
internacional
a su electorado a mí me parece que es un
error la relación entre China y Estados
Unidos es la más importante que hay en
el mundo y al mismo tiempo la más
peligrosa Sergio le traslado a usted
este tema tanto china como Estados
Unidos reconocen que compiten por el
poder por digamos la hegemonía
internacional sin embargo
declara no que ven necesario tener
canales de comunicación abiertos para
evitar escaladas mayores de qué estamos
hablando con estos canales de
comunicación si usted nos lo puede
explicar Y qué tipo de riesgo se quieren
evitar Pues yo pensaría que el primero
son los encuentros diplomáticos cara a
cara como el que protagonizó blinken
pero en anteriores oportunidades la
última vez que se reunió el jefe de
estado de china con el jefe de estado de
Estados Unidos Fue cuando Barack Obama
en el 2015 invitó a esos son ocho años
de estos líderes no verse las caras
invitados a una visita de estado del uno
al otro porque en de poros regionales se
reúnen etcétera lo que está en juego acá
es Taiwán o sea Ese es el fondo y usted
mencionó los Microchips y los
semiconductores Este es el quick del
asunto realmente no nos dejemos engañar
China de Estados Unidos son mutuamente
dependientes en materia comercial pero
la geopolítica que está en juego es
evitar una escalada como la que Rusia ha
hecho en Ucrania Pero esta vez en el
lado de Pacífico Sur que es Taiwán y Qué
elementos podrían Conducir a desescalar
Cuáles son las claves para desescalar
estas tensiones Pues en primer lugar
Estados Unidos ya declaró que iba a
explorar formas de desescalar su
industria de semiconductores para no
depender exclusivamente de Taiwán pues
depender de Taiwán exclusivamente para
esta industria coloca una fuerte presión
para un escalamiento automático de las
tensiones entre esos países pero yo creo
que la dependencia económica que entre
esos dos países hace muy difícil que hay
un conflicto prolongado y que hay un
conflicto bélico que realmente pase a la
acción yo creo que esto se va a quedar
unas tensiones comerciales que van a
dificultar el comercio internacional
sanciones quizás pero también no va a
ser un conflicto que únicamente se va a
quedar en Taiwán como otros seguro van a
hablar más luego en este segmento y
rápidamente porque lo hemos anunciado y
hay que hay que comentarlo también
Estados Unidos en su estrategia en Asia
cuenta con un Aliado también un poco
ambivalente y es la India y se ha
ilustrado esta Alianza con la visita a
Washington del Primer Ministro indio
narendra modi Qué puede conseguir cada
uno de los bandos Estados Unidos India
en este refuerzo de las relaciones muy
rápidamente Salvador no tenemos mucho
tiempo
Sí bueno Me parece que coincido con
Guzmán en el asunto de que
van a seguir tensiones de carácter
comercial no va a escalar de de una
manera importante y Bueno pues la la
India juega ahí un papel central de
media de mediación y de diálogo con los
distintos países también por el lado el
lado comercial entonces me parece que el
asunto hay que seguirlo con atención
pero no va a escalar a mayores
circunstancias Pues no sé si tiene algo
más que Añadir respecto a la cuestión de
la India Sergio o pasamos a otro bloqueo
rápidamente quiero hacer un comentario
mire rápidamente Yo creo que el problema
con latinoamérica es que llega muy tarde
a estas tendencias china es un asunto
que geopolíticamente viene cobrando
relevancia los últimos 20 años pero uno
de los grandes actores que jugará
relevancia en los próximos 20 años será
justamente India ya por ser el país más
poblado del mundo sino por su poderío
económico y no estamos poniendo la
atención en este en esta región del
mundo Entonces clave lo que usted dice
quinta potencia económica mundial y a la
India y ya como como usted bien le decía
primera Potencia demográfica de todo el
mundo tras superar este mismo año a
China pues Les propongo que ahora
vayamos con una cuestión que afecta a
nuestra región América Latina vamos
concretamente a Centroamérica donde Este
martes conocimos la noticia de que una
reyerta en una cárcel de Honduras muy
cerca a la capital Tegucigalpa acabó con
46 personas muertas 46 mujeres porque
esto sucedió en un centro penitenciario
femenino se mezcló una reyerta con un
incendio causas que todavía no están a
del todo claras sin embargo lo que sí
que apunta a la prensa local es que se
trató de una discusión de una batalla
entre pandillas entre la Mara
Salvatrucha y barrio 18 lo que sin duda
alguna hace centrar de nuevo la atención
en la guerra de las pandillas en
Centroamérica y En cómo abordarla qué
alternativas hay a la mano dura del
presidente del Salvador nayib bukele una
mano dura que ha sido inspiración al
menos declarada de los principales
aspirantes a la presidencia de Guatemala
que recordemos este domingo va a primera
vuelta electoral tanto Sandra Torres
como
Zurich se declaran admiradores en menor
o mayor grado de los efectos que está
teniendo la política de bukele en el
Salvador entonces les pregunto temoris
empezó por usted qué alternativas para
acabar con la violencia en Centroamérica
que no sean esta mano dura de bukele
Bueno sobre sobre India que no que no
tuve oportunidad de comentar claro
quería bueno insistir en que hay que
trasladarle al público la idea de que
India no es un Aliado de alguien no es
un subordinado de alguien Y de Rusia ni
de China ni de Estados Unidos y cada vez
va a ser más asertiva en la medida en
que en que en que su potencial de su
potencia su poder demográfico y
económico va a crecer y va a establecer
relaciones con las otras potencias en la
medida de sus propios intereses Ya no
como como como como subordinado y en
cuanto esto eso es muy peligroso eh
bukele o sea en Centroamérica vive
varias crisis la crisis de desarrollo la
crisis económica la crisis climática y
la crisis de seguridad pública porque él
está mostrando un camino para resolver
solamente una de esas de esas crisis y
es el camino de la violación sistemática
e institucional de los Derechos Humanos
que sur y ríos que que es pues
finalmente representa
la ultraderecha más violenta en en
Joaquín Guatemala este recuperando este
discurso pero que de pronto también
Sandra Torres que es la que va apuntando
en las encuestas o que en el caso de
Honduras Un gobierno que se que que se
supone que es izquierda como de como el
de Xiomara este
retomando este discurso
creo que que conduce a una derechización
del ambiente político que es muy
peligroso en la medida en que las
propias poblaciones están ya queriendo
confiar más en la mano dura
independientemente de lo que esto
implique y pasando por encima de los
Derechos Humanos
Salvador le le trasladó la misma
pregunta también antes de México cómo
cómo ve este cómo nos decía temories no
que la población digamos acepte y vea
esta esta política de mano dura con
buenos ojos
bueno el modelo bukele está sirviendo de
inspiración para las derechas
latinoamericanas en el caso de México
empresarios de
poderosos han dicho que en México
deberían aplicarse ese tipo de medidas
por fortuna actualmente los gobiernos de
países como México y como Colombia no no
creo que apliquen y que se sientan
inspirados por este modelo bukele que
atenta contra los Derechos Humanos pero
Eh pues hay que seguirlo con mucha
atención porque como dice temores el
problema de la migración el problema de
las pandillas el problema de de estos
conflictos que se desarrollan en las
cárceles de América Latina y de otros
países
no puede ser resuelto solamente mirando
la represión y resolver el asunto de
manera temporal es decir el problema de
fondo es
desigualdad en el modelo económico que
hay en los países de América Latina es
decir no podemos resolver la migración
si no se atienden los problemas
económicos las oportunidades de empleo
disminuir los índices de inseguridad
entonces
atender la desigualdad es un asunto que
no veo en la en el corto plazo pero que
es el asunto de fondo para que modelos
derechistas como el de bukele no andan
en la región Y Sergio más que centrarnos
en la migración un tema que ya
abordaremos en otra ocasión en la
cuestión de las pandillas nos apuntaba
Salvador desde México no la lucha contra
la desigualdad a corto plazo esto como
se puede traducir no no se puede
traducir más que en crecimiento
económico y en un crecimiento económico
con una redistribución de recursos ya
sea por medio de obras ya sea por medio
de impuestos o que sea por medio
prosperidad compartida y eso ya hemos
sabido que los presidentes de izquierda
en la región tampoco han sido muy buenos
en hacerlo sí se han propuesto aumentar
impuestos se ha propuesto hacer más
burocracia y eso desincentiva Los
inversionistas Internacionales a venir a
muchos países añado es muy seductivo
para muchos gobiernos y particularmente
candidatos decir yo lo que voy a hacer
es mano dura y va a haber una solución
las soluciones no son ni a corto plazo
ni son fáciles de hacer pero no podemos
estar saltando de derecha izquierda
izquierda derecha extremo a extremo sin
realmente sentarnos y preguntar si los
la continuidad de las políticas va a
tener efecto Pues bueno lamentablemente
no tenemos más tiempo para debatir esta
cuestión que es muy amplia veremos en
Guatemala Hacia dónde acaba dirigiéndose
la política de seguridad entre entre
otras cuestiones y Les propongo cerrar
con un tema que ya avanzábamos al
principio de este programa y es la
ambivalencia francesa respecto a la
discurso y al liderazgo en la lucha
contra el cambio climático Y es que
recordemos que estos este final de
semana el presidente francés Emmanuel
macron ha sido anfitrión de una cumbre
en París con decenas de líderes
mundiales en la que querían transformar
el sistema financiero internacional para
unir en una mismo combate Por decirlo
así la lucha contra la pobreza y la
lucha contra el cambio climático sin
embargo paralelamente esta misma semana
el ministro del interior francés de una
línea muy dura gerardman ha presentado
el decreto de disolución de una
movimiento
llamadolesmundo laterg los el
levantamiento de la tierra una
disolución que por un lado es polémica
porque el movimiento no tiene una
estructura legal como tal Y que por otro
lado incluso medios como lomont han
cuestionado porque el ministro de
interior francés acusado estos grupos de
ecoterroristas Y esto no por referirse a
empresas que son muy contaminantes y no
precisamente activistas que utilizan
directa para defender su lucha contra el
cambio climático les planteo rápidamente
para cerrar este programa no tenemos
mucho tiempo temorís Empezando por usted
que le predece esta ambivalencia
acusar de terrorismo a opositores o a
disidentes que no han cometido que
terroristas y que no han asesinado a
nadie es un recurso propio de gobiernos
autoritarios el gobierno francés que a
mí me parece que como muy muchos otros
gobiernos quiere decidir unilateralmente
y sin consultar qué es lo bueno y qué es
lo malo para hacer con respecto al
cambio climático sin escuchar a la gente
y este este me parece que es un reflejo
de decepcionante El hacer esta acusación
y además tratar de disolver que no lo
van a poder hacer a este grupo
Sí de hecho en la relación
en la editorial de lomón que
comentábamos precisamente no critican
este uso incluso de una ley no de esta
ley contra el separatismo tan polémica
que aprobó Francia en 2021 y que dicen
amplía lamentablemente no las
condiciones para acusar de terrorismo a
alguien antes ha dado condiciones que
antes solo aplicaban a grupos armados o
que hacían apología abierta del odio no
Salvador le pregunto desde México
también Qué le parece este escenario
Me parece que el movimiento
ambientalista mundial es uno de los
signos de nuestro tiempo más
interesantes veo más organizados a los
movimientos sociales en defensa del
medio ambiente que alzan la voz contra
el cambio climático ahora mismo en en
México tenemos temperaturas de cuarenta
cuarenta y cinco grados que no se veían
en nuestro país
pues jamás
entonces hay mucho más organización en
el movimiento social que tiene que ver
con el medio ambiente lo cual lo veo
positivo que entre los países que
intentan combatir de manera unilateral
este este problema el asunto del
multilateralismo entre las naciones para
poder abordar y enfrentar este asunto es
un asunto central porque hemos visto
dirigentes
negacionistas como incluso Donald Trump
decía que el cambio
climático no es un importante que no
existe que es un engaño de las
izquierdas y de los socialistas y de los
comunistas Bueno pues no hay ahí un tema
de diálogo sino discursos huecos sin
sustancia por parte de los países sin
embargo Me parece que hay que subrayar
es una de las luchas más importantes que
significan a nuestro tiempo el
movimiento medioambiental más el tema
del movimiento
que señala asuntos sobre las
problemáticas de las migraciones y el
feminismo son los tres asuntos grandes
que está discutiendo la sociedad que es
más sabia que las potencias sin duda y
una y tres temas que que mueven
muchísimos muchísimos intereses Opuestos
no Sergio para concluir también esta
ronda que le parece esta esta dicotomía
pues Mire yo creo que nos pusieron a
hablar a todos de ellos Entonces de
cierta forma el hecho de que el estado
haya perseguirlos les va a dar muchísima
más visibilidad a ellos y a sus temas y
yo creo que los grupos medioambientales
hoy en día están recurriendo a cualquier
tipo de estrategia para hacernos caer en
cuenta de que la emergencia climática es
real y que necesitan nuestra atención
inmediata pues muchísimas gracias esta
atención le intentamos dar a esta
cuestión que bueno está es cuestión de
vida o muerte para nuestra supervivencia
les agradezco a los tres su
participación te morís Muchísimas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
aquí en France 24 Muchísimas gracias por
habernos aportado su punto de vista
respecto a las relaciones con India y
disculpe por haberlo saltado en un
primer momento por haberme despistado
muy interesante su reflexión sobre esta
ambivalencia y esta India buscando
siempre sus propios intereses Salvador
también le agradezco muchísimo desde
México su participación Sergio también
aquí en los estudios de France 24
ustedes llegamos así al final de esta
Edición de una semana en el mundo pero
recuerden que pueden ampliar toda esta y
más información en France 24 y 24 punto
com
[Música]